Durante los primeros días de 2022, solo se
hablaba de una cosa: ¡Vienen los rusos!
La acumulación de en la frontera con Ucrania
parecía dejar claro que la invasión era
cuestión de tiempo
Sin embargo, en aquel momento, las expectativas
que tenía prácticamente todo el mundo eran
la de un paseo triunfal.
¿Lo recordáis?
N1(15 de febrero de 2022: Las armas estadounidenses
enviadas a Ucrania mitigarían, pero no detendrían
una invasión rusa. El ejército ruso podría
abrumar rápidamente a las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas, incluso a las que están respaldadas
por Estados Unidos y sus aliados europeos.
NYTimes)
N2(5 de enero 2022: El ejército de Ucrania
tiene fondos insuficientes, está superado
en armas y no está listo para detener una
invasión rusa. Bloomberg)
Estos son tan solo dos ejemplos de lo que
parecía un consenso general: salvo sorpresa
mayúscula, las fuerzas armadas de Ucrania
no tenían nada que hacer ante la gigantesca
y poderosa maquinaria bélica de Rusia.
En aquel momento se hablaba de cosas como
la evacuación de Zelenski o la puesta en
marcha de una guerra de guerrillas…
Sin embargo, los ucranianos resistieron. Y
lo hicieron contra viento y marea.
Durante meses y meses los ucranianos han visto
cómo sus ciudades, sus pueblos y sus campos
están siendo arrasados. Las bajas, por su
parte, se cuentan por decenas y decenas de
miles.
Los rusos han destruido centrales eléctricas,
miles de colegios, cientos de hospitales y
todo tipo de infraestructuras. Para que os
hagáis una idea, en abril de 2023 la estimación
de los daños directos provocados por la guerra
superaba ya los 150 mil millones de dólares.
Los ucranianos han tenido que hacer frente
a las bombas, al frío y a la oscuridad. Y,
sin embargo, han resistido. Y no solo eso.
Ahora, incluso, vuelven a tener la iniciativa…
Digamos que los ucranianos no estaban a dispuestos
a perder esta guerra bajo ninguna circunstancia
y ahora, ahora quieren ganarla.
La pregunta, la gran pregunta que todavía
no hemos respondido es: ¿Por qué los ucranianos
pese a todo quieren seguir luchando?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, aquí en VisualPolitik,
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
[Pero antes dejadme haceros solo un apunte:
¿te gusta lo que hacemos? ¿Quieres ayudarnos
a crecer y al mismo recibir un montón de
contenido extra? Pues… Tan solo tenéis
que sumaros a nuestra comunidad de Patreon.
Con una pequeña ayuda podréis hacer que
este proyecto siga creciendo y mejorando,
y además, recibiréis nuestro boletín especial
“Las Claves de la Semana”, merchandising
único y mucho más contenido. Os dejamos
toda la info en la descripción.
Muchísimas gracias de corazón a todos los
que ya nos dais vuestro apoyo.]
Y ahora sí… Arranquemos.
Creo que si hay algo en lo que todos podemos
estar de acuerdo es en el gran mérito que
ha tenido la resistencia numantina de Ucrania.
Vale que ahora sabemos que el armamento y
el ejército ruso tenían más agujeros que
un queso gruyer, vale que ahora sabemos que
la enorme corrupción lo ha dejado seco. Y
vale que todos hemos visto los enormes flujos
de armas que han llegado a Ucrania de sus
aliados occidentales.
Pero claro, haber resistido contra un ejército
superior en número, en armas, en fuerza,
área, en artillería y prácticamente en
cualquier campo es algo que tiene mucho, muchísimo
mérito.
Pongámonos en su lugar, no es fácil ver
cómo el oso ruso se te abalanza encima y
mantener el cuchillo entre los dientes…
Y, sin embargo, eso exactamente lo que han
hecho los ucranianos.
Por supuesto, el precio a pagar ha sido altísimo…
Y lo será aún más.
En Ucrania la destrucción, la aniquilación
y las bajas son ya el pan de cada día. ¿Recordáis
las imágenes que dejó la voladura de la
presa de Nova Kajovka? Pues así todo.
Y, sin embargo, a pesar de ello, las encuestas
dicen que la inmensa mayor parte de los ucranianos
quieren luchar hasta el final. Quieren echar
a los rusos de su país, cueste lo que cueste.
¿No me creéis? ¿Pensáis que exagero? Pues
fijaos:
(Más del 80% de los ucranianos se oponen
a las concesiones territoriales, aun a riesgo
de una guerra prolongada. Yahoo News)
Pero, ¿Cómo es posible que, con todo en
contra, no decidieran bajar los brazos cuándo
comenzó la invasión? ¿Por qué no lo hacen
ahora?
¿Por qué diantres quieren los ucranianos
seguir peleando? ¿Por qué tantos y tantos
jóvenes están dispuestos a llegar hasta
el final?
Queridos amigos, amigas, la resistencia ucraniana
tiene varios ingredientes que se han ido cocinando
a fuego lento.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? Para conocer el primero
de ellos tenemos que remontarnos hasta comienzos
del siglo XX. Concretamente, hasta octubre
de 1917, cuando la revolución estalló en
el Imperio Ruso y todo saltó por los aires.
También en Ucrania, que primero se proclamó
como una república independiente de Rusia
y luego sufrió una guerra civil entre dos
bandos:
La República Popular Ucraniana, asistida
por Alemania y el Imperio Austro-Húngaro,
por un lado, y la República Socialista Soviética
de Ucrania, apoyada por los bolcheviques por
otro.
Al final fueron los segundos quienes se llevaron
el gato al agua y en 1922 Ucrania se unió
a Rusia, Bielorrusia y Transcaucasia para
formar la URSS, la Unión de Repúblicas Socialistas
Soviéticas.
Moscú volvía a estar al mando. Lo que el
tiempo demostró que fue un absoluto desastre.
(Para la década de los años 30, los beneficios
de haberse integrado en la Unión Soviética
prácticamente habían desaparecido. La política
agraria de Stalin basada en la confiscación
y la colectivización de las tierras afectó
como a ningún otro a un territorio que era
conocido como “el granero de la URSS”.
Los campesinos que trataron de mantener su
tierra fueron reprimidos, deportados a campos
de concentración e, incluso, ejecutados.)
¿El resultado?
Murieron de hambre entre 3,5 y 8 millones
de ucranianos. En el mejor de los casos hablamos
de que el 10% de la población de Ucrania
se murió de hambre por culpa de las decisiones
tomadas en Moscú. Fue lo que posteriormente
se ha conocido como “Holodomor”.
Pero eso no fue más que el comienzo.
Durante los años del estalinismo el soviet
supremo promovió activamente la rusificación
de Ucrania. Lo que suponía restringir e,
incluso, suprimir el uso del ucraniano y cualquier
otro aspecto de la cultura local. Por supuesto,
todo esto significó mucha más represión.
Tras Stalin, los ucranianos tuvieron un breve
tiempo de respiro durante la etapa de Nikita
Jruschov al frente del Imperio Rojo, pero
después en Moscú volvieron a las mismas.
Y luego, tras años de pobreza y mano dura,
para colmo, en 1986 se produjo el desastre
de Chernóbil que fue, otra vez, terriblemente
mal gestionado por la cúpula soviética de
Moscú.
Así que, ya lo veis… Durante décadas Moscú
y, por tanto, Rusia y los rusos por extensión,
no hicieron que digamos muchos puntos para
ganarse el corazón de los ucranianos.
Y quizás por eso, tras la perestroika y el
colapso de la URSS en octubre de 1991, estos
lo tuvieron muy claro: querían volver a ser
un país independiente. Y como decimos por
aquí, dicho y hecho.
Los ucranianos votaron en un referéndum y
la independencia ganó por una aplastante
mayoría. Fijaos.
Y, ojo, porque tal y como podéis ver la independencia
ganó en todas las regiones del país… Ganó
por inmensa mayoría en el Donbass y también
ganó en Crimea y en Sebastopol.
Claro que, un momento, porque la independencia
no logró que los tentáculos y la influencia
de Moscú se terminarán. Todo lo contrario.
T1(PERDIENDO EL TREN A BRUSELAS)
En prácticamente todos los países post-soviéticos
la transición para dejar atrás el comunismo
fue terriblemente dura. Todo estaba por hacer.
Y por supuesto en Ucrania las cosas no fueron
diferentes.
El sector público era un desastre, el gigantesco
aparato estatal y la asfixiante dependencia
de Moscú estaba por todas partes. Y los países
tenían que reconstruirse de arriba a abajo
en medio de una brutal crisis económica.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre 1991 y
1998 la economía de Ucrania se desplomó
más de un 60%.
Y de hecho, no empezó a dar síntomas de
mejora hasta la llegada del nuevo siglo…
Pero luego, pocos años después, llegó la
gran crisis financiera y todo se fue, otra
vez, al garete. Un desastre. El país parecía
condenado a no escapar del pozo.
Sin embargo, tras la gran crisis del 2008
algo cambió, de pronto surgió la posibilidad
de firmar un Acuerdo de Asociación con la
Unión Europea.
¿Y sabéis lo que esto significaba? ¡El
acceso al mercado común podría cambiarlo
todo! De repente, los productos ucranianos
podrían fluir hacia el oeste como si no hubiera
mañana. Y las inversiones europeas podrían
ayudar a modernizar el país.
Sin embargo, contened la euforia porque había
un problema y no precisamente uno pequeño.
¿Adivináis cuál? 3,2,1… ¡Exacto! Moscú.
Las negociaciones con la Unión Europea empezaron
viento en popa y a toda vela. Sin embargo,
cuando parecían estar a punto de llegar a
buen puerto… De repente descarrilaron por
completo.
El Presidente Víktor Yanukóvich, que había
prometido sacar adelante este acuerdo, congeló
el proceso. Por supuesto, detrás de este
movimiento estaba Rusia.
N4(21 de noviembre de 2013: Ucrania abandona
su plan de ir hacia Occidente y gira hacia
Oriente. El primer ministro de Yanukóvich
dio la dramática orden de suspender el proceso
en interés de la "seguridad nacional" y reanudar
el "diálogo activo" con Moscú. Reuters)
La idea de que las repúblicas ex-soviéticas
fueran por ahí coqueteando con occidente
era algo que Putin no estaba dispuesto a consentir.
Le molestaba más que a Drácula un ajo en
el desayuno.
Así que Yanukóvich y todos los ucranianos
se tendrían que rendir a su poder.
El problema, el problema querida comunidad,
es que en 2013, al igual que en 2022, el presidente
ruso no calibró bien la voluntad de los ucranianos
por dejarse mangonear.
Y entonces se desató el desastre… ¡Atentos!
T2(LA OBSTINADA ESPERANZA)
El día 22 de noviembre de 2013, nada más
anunciarse la congelación del acuerdo con
la Unión Europea, la Plaza de la Independencia
de Kyiv, habitualmente conocida como Maidan,
empezó a ponerse al rojo vivo.
Partidos políticos, plataformas sociales,
activistas… De repente, esta plaza se convirtió
en el epicentro de una gigantesca protesta
contra el gobierno de miles y miles de personas.
Toda la oposición a Yanukovich y a sus lazos
con Moscú estaban representados en este lugar.
(Era exactamente el mismo lugar donde en el
año 2004 se había producido la revolución
naranja contra el robo electoral para hacer
presidente al mismo Yanukovich en detrimento
de su oponente proeuropeo Viktor Yushchenko,
quien por cierto fue envenenado durante la
campaña electoral de ese mismo año. ¿Que
quién lo envenenó? No se ha podido determinar,
pero ya os imaginaréis a donde se dirigen
todas las sospechas… En este caso como en
tantos otros, todos los caminos apuntan a
Moscú)
Pero no nos desviemos.
El caso es que la situación escaló rápidamente.
Y en enero del 2014 el gobierno intento desalojar
la plaza mediante una dura represión que
dejó decenas de muertos y heridos. En ese
momento los manifestantes se organizaron creando
Unidades de Defensa.
Ucrania estaba al borde del abismo… Por
fortuna, todo terminó con la dimisión y
la huida del país del presidente Yanukóvich.
Lo que, por otra parte, significaba una dura
derrota para Moscú.
Pero… Un momento, ¿todo término de verdad?
Por supuesto que no… Vladímir Putin no
iba a quedarse de brazos cruzados. Seguro
que todos recordáis noticias como estas:
N5(1 de marzo 2014: La "invasión" rusa de
Crimea aviva el temor a un conflicto en Ucrania.
The Guardian)
N6(7 de marzo 2014: 21 periodistas han confirmado
que las tropas enmascaradas en Crimea son
rusas. Mashable)
Efectivamente. Putin dio un golpe en la mesa
y decidió contraatacar. Lo hizo invadiendo
primero y anexionándose después la provincia
ucraniana de Crimea. Al mismi tiempo alimentó
una guerra civil en el Donbass, la región
más rica y desarrollada de toda Ucrania.
En ese momento Ucrania no pudo hacer prácticamente
nada:
C1(“Solo unos 50.000 soldados podrían haberse
desplegado cuando comenzó la guerra en Crimea,
en febrero de 2014; pero de esos, solo alrededor
de 6.000 estaban listos para el combate. (…) La
operación rusa terminó efectivamente con
dos salvajes derrotas de las fuerzas ucranianas.”
Análisis de The Jamestown Foundation, julio
de 2021)
¿El resultado? La pérdida de CrEimea y la
proclamación de dos nuevas repúblicas - hoy
anexionadas también por Rusia: La República
Popular de Donetsk y la República Popular
de Lugansk. Dos estados títeres de Moscú.
¿Y sabéis qué? Esta operación también
fue un auténtico desastre.
En las nuevas repúblicas, las instituciones
fueron asaltadas; se impuso un modelo ultranacionalista,
ultraconservador y ultramilitarizado. Muchas,
por no decir, la mayoría de las grandes empresas
y los activos productivos, como las minas
o las fábricas de acero, fueron expropiadas
o puestas a disposición de oligarcas amigos
de Moscú.
¿El resultado?
La actividad económica se hundió y los empleos
desaparecieron. Se calcula que cerca de la
mitad, ojo la mitad de toda la población,
hizo las maletas y se marchó a Rusia, al
resto de Europa y, sobre todo, al resto de
Ucrania… Sobre todo a regiones próximas
como Járkiv.
Evidentemente, como os podéis imaginar, a
todas estas personas, Moscú tampoco les traslada
emociones precisamente positivas.
Fijaos en lo que decía un escritor de la
región a finales del 2021:
C2("Han logrado reconstruir un sistema soviético
en los territorios ocupados, y no el sistema
soviético de las décadas de 1960 y 1970,
sino el sistema soviético de las décadas
de 1930 y 1940, con mazmorras, con cámaras
de tortura, un sistema donde las vidas se
arruinan si te atreves a escribir o decir
algo negativo sobre estas repúblicas y sus
autoridades". Stanislav Aseev, novelista y
periodista de Donetsk)
Y eso no es todo. La intervención rusa hizo
que Ucrania se viera obligada a reconstruir
sus fuerzas armadas. Es decir, que por culpa
de Rusia, desde comienzos del año 2014 el
que era el país más pobre de toda Europa
tuvo que más que duplicar su gasto militar.
Desde luego el tiempo les dio la razón. Hacia
mucha falta.
La buena noticia para Ucrania fue que la ayuda
internacional también empezó a llegar. Fijaos.
N7(24 de febrero de 2015: Entrenamiento militar
del Reino Unido en Ucrania: movimiento simbólico
que pone en riesgo la ira rusa. The Guardian)
23 de noviembre de 2015: Las tropas estadounidenses
comienzan a entrenar a las fuerzas regulares
ucranianas. DefenseNews)
Y así, poco a poco fue como Ucrania y sobre
todo los ucranianos se fueron preparando para
la guerra… Hasta que el 24 de febrero de
2022 Putin finalmente desató su tormenta
de fuego.
Claro que desde entonces ha pasado mucho tiempo
y la guerra no solo continua, sino que ahora
son los propios ucranianos quienes llevan
la iniciativa.
Pero… ¿Realmente qué explica su enorme
tenacidad?
Queridos amigos, amigas, hagamos si os parece
un pequeño ejercicio.
Imaginémonos por un momento que volvemos
al 25 de febrero de 2022, somos ucranianos
y somos jóvenes. La invasión rusa acaba
de comenzar. Los misiles caen sobre Ucrania,
al tiempo que las hordas de Putin intentan
alcanzar las principales ciudades del país,
incluyendo la capital.
Hemos nacido en una Ucrania independiente
dónde, sin embargo, los tentáculos de Moscú
están por todas partes. Tus abuelos te han
hablado del Holodomor y de los familiares
que perdieron por culpa de Moscú. También
te han contado cómo la Unión Soviética
intentó rusificar Ucrania… Tus padres te
han hablado de lo difícil que fue su vida,
de la represión y seguramente también de
la policía política, la temida KGB.
Has leído sobre el desastre de Chernóbil.
Has vivido el intento de Moscú de que tu
país cortara sus lazos con Occidente y la
posterior revolución del Euromaidán. Has
conocido el horror de la guerra del 2014 y
pueda que conozcas a gente que murió, que
fue víctima o que fue movilizada durante
esa guerra.
Pese a todo, durante los últimos años has
soñado con que Ucrania se modernice y se
abrace a los países más ricos y prósperos
de Europa, pero ahora, en cambio, vuelves
a presenciar cómo el gobierno ruso sigue
destrozando y aniquilando tu país con bombas,
misiles, tanques y soldados.
Así que la pregunta que muchos ucranianos
se hicieron y todavía se hacen es, ¿cómo
demonios no luchar?
De esta forma la mayoría de los ucranianos
han llegado a una conclusión muy clara: o
derrotan a Rusia de una vez por todas o nunca
podrán tener un país normal, próspero y
en paz.
Rusia se ha convertido en su peor pesadilla.
Sin embargo, si lo consiguen, si consiguen
derro tar a Rusia, Ucrania podría en unos
años llegar a incorporarse a la Unión Europea
y a la OTAN e intentar así emular el impresionante
desarrollo de países como Polonia o las repúblicas
bálticas.
Y eso, eso es exactamente lo que explica la
noticia que veíamos antes:
(Más del 80% de los ucranianos se oponen
a las concesiones territoriales, aun a riesgo
de una guerra prolongada. Yahoo News)
Cómo podéis ver en los resultados de esta
encuesta dirigida por el Instituto Internacional
de Sociología de Kyiv, los ucranianos mayormente
están dispuestos a seguir luchando para recuperar
su territorio.
Ya lo veis, es, por así decirlo, una apuesta
de todo o nada.
La pregunta, ¿Lo conseguirán? ¿Lograrán
derrotar a Rusia? ¿Si fueses ucraniano como
hubieras reaccionado ante la invasión rusa?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y, como siempre, abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like. Y si te gusta lo
que hacemos, quieres echarnos una mano y al
mismo tiempo recibir más contenidos, date
un paseo por nuestro Patreon. Os dejamos en
la descripción toda la información.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.